want to talk about uh healthcare resource utilization uh when you look at the cost
margins with full outpatient biospecific antibody delivery versus what is billed
during inpatient step-up dosing or inpatient delivery of these important medications so
we have heard over the last few days eloquently from many colleagues about bispecifics and myeloma
this is just a little bit of landscape over the last dozen years or so it's very clear that myeloma
is not the only space with Bispecific presence we have a several different solid tumor
etiologies with bispecific therapies on the market already uh and about four different bites for
myeloma it's important to note that all four of them are rams associated um you know relevant
correlate is in lymphoma we have apcoridomab glofetimab and mosentuzumab all three that are
actually not rams associated so you know in my conversations with uh colleagues and community
this does represent actually some of the most important factors that we can consider when we
look at myeloma and myeloma in the community and i think it's important to note that this is
a very significant hurdle in terms of their desire and willingness and capability to try to on board
for these drugs in the community this has been talked about in general uh over the last few days
but clearly bispecifics have really significantly improved outcomes in relapsed refractory heavily
pretreated patients so we went from single agent responses in 20 to 32 percent or so range with uh
you know prior versions of proteasome inhibitors immunomodulatory drugs cd38 antibodies xpo1
rs2 you know more than double that uh with uh teclistamab l-renatamab talquitamab
len vaseltamab as i mentioned uh uh is a new arrival as well that performs
in this range as well and and clearly medium progression free survival has been tripled at least
with these therapies the key problem however is the dissemination and penetration of these drugs
into the community and broadening the access of these agents for a broader impact this is just
a little bit of summary uh in terms of incidence timing duration of the crs and icons crs really
representing sort of the main hurdle when somebody wants to onboard for Bispecific therapy
so the early uh experiences with the clistamab l-renatamab uh median onset of about you know
two days and duration of about two days um glen vaseltamab as the most recent arrival
notably is iv agent so you can appreciate the fact that uh median time to onset and you're
the duration are measured in hours not days so this does represent some level of predictability
maybe if you want to uh plan around it uh i'll mention in a moment what that uh looks like in
terms of a label recommended step up dosing and admissions talquitamab can be given weekly or
every two weeks uh it's sort of in between the lenovo in tech and elra uh with median time to
answer about 25 uh you know 27 hours with the q2 weekly dosing which is certainly how i use it
um this is just a quick summary of uh what it means if you look at the label to give to clistamab
usually uh the step-up doses are separated uh by two days uh there is a 48 hospitalization
that is recommendation of a label after each step of dosing if you look at the l-renatamab
notable differences that after the first step of dosing the second step of dosing can be observed
for 24 instead of 48 hours and then the first full dose can actually be the
in the outpatient setting in terms of talquitamab i give it every q2 weekly to all my patients so
that does expand the dosings in terms of the step-up doses and it can go as as high as 12
days if you admit for 48 hours after each step of dose and then when the saltimab has a slightly
different logistics where you give it uh in week one and week two with 24 hour recommended
hospitalization also so this as you can see does require certain inpatient stays
so others have looked at uh and before we go there just to remind about the cost of contemporary
myeloma therapies this is there are rvrd frontline annualized classes just over four hundred thousand
dollars there are krd you know 578 thousand dollars this is car keys which are over half
a million and then you have uh bella which is about 370 and then the bispecifics that range
from two hundred and thirty or so with tech to tell three hundred seventy range of three hundred
and four hundred eighty six with uh l run atom maya colleagues uh looked at this a little bit
and in their 34 patient cohort 17 of each received tech and tal last majority of their dosings were
administered and built outpatient however certain amount of their high-cost medications including
tactile as well as stosi were built under inpatient encounter whether it was just choice of inpatient
administration or because people had to be admitted or ended up getting the rest of it stepped up in
patient so if you account for all of the cost of high risk or high-cost drugs then they had about
a hundred and fifteen thousand dollar saving in their experience so at vanderbilt our initial
experience after approval of uh bispecifics early on this is a 51 patient cohort 34 of tech tal 24
patients the notable differences are of course in the exposure to prior b-semiotherapy tal group uh
having of course a more bcm exposure particularly cardiac exposure compared to others to the other
side you can uh appreciate a couple of these points of relevance so inpatient step-up initiation was
done in just 58 percent of patients uh so that's a significant chunk of what we do these days we
give about 90 outpatient and only rarely do we admit somebody because they're frail or have high
tumor burden and we really want to observe them so initial experiences were label driven
and we really want to observe them so initial experiences were label driven
only about 20 patients actually got it uh only fully outpatient and then four patients got a
hybrid um these were heavily pre-treated patients median six prior lines of therapy in both groups
um hospitalization days for those that were inpatient a median was eight but ranged from
six to twelve if you look at the hybrid patients it's about half that so four days ranging from one
to five now if you look at the overall cohort there's about 306 hospitalization days that were
potentially avoidable with the step-up dosing schedule inside those three or six days there's
20 that were used for grade 1 serious management initially we no longer admit for grade 1 crs we
manage it outpatient and we have noticed that there is no need for any admissions
but if you take a look at the national inpatient sample analysis where charges this is you know six
years old at this point seven a cost of hospitalization day was sixteen thousand dollars
so that represents almost five million dollars of hospitalization charges that can be saved
additionally if you account for inpatient versus outpatient high cost margins including tosi
120 inpatient versus uh outpatient tactile doses were given and then we also had 13
tosi doses of which 10 were inpatient for crs treatment so if you take a margin of high risk
or rather high cost drug charging from outpatient to inpatient if you apply
it to this number of doses that's an additional one and a half million dollars saved just in our
51 patients which overall represents over six and a half million dollars of cost savings had
everything been outpatient had we not admitted for a grade 1 crs this excludes anybody who had to be
admitted for infection management for legitimate like a grade 2 crs rarely happens this you know
was not polluted by that analysis and lastly important to mention that this cost analysis
actually under representation at vanderbilt is a 340 b institution so we have acquisition costs
that are significantly below the market uh and these are actually based on uh
assessments that are in mayo clinic which is not 340 b institution thank you very much